Now let's explore the project section,
this is optional but highly recommended.
It can be an especially helpful way to
demonstrate your practical experience.
When creating content for
your project section, there are a few
guidelines to keep in mind.
Include the project title as well as
a concise description about the project.
Use keywords and
note any coding languages you applied,
the most recent projects
would be at the top.
Finally, keep in mind that you
can adjust the placement of your
projects in your overall
LinkedIn profile.
If you are trying to switch careers
entirely, placing your projects
above your work experience may better
reflect your goals to recruiters.